الرئيس الامريكي والمستشار الالماني
تعهدان بمعاقبه روسيا بسبب حربها في
اوكرانيا
هيئه النزاهه العراقيه تامر بالقبض على
اربعه مسؤولين سابقين بينهم وزير الماليه
علي علاوي
والمبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران يدعو الى
محاسبه المسؤولين عن تسمم فتيات بمدارس
ايرانيه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
عقد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن والمستشار
الالماني
اجتماعا خاصا في المكتب البيضاوي واتعهد
بعيدا في الاجتماع الذي استمر اكثر من
ساعه بمواصله جعل روسيا تدفع ثمن حربها في
اوكرانيا وشدد على اهميه استمرار التضامن
العالمي مع الشعب الاوكراني والجهود
المستمره لتوفير الامن والمساعده
الانسانيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
فرضت الولايات المتحده عقوبات على سته
مواطنين روس بمن فيهم نائب وزير العدل
وقضى وموظفي لجنه التحقيق
وبحسب بيان الخزانه الامريكيه فان
العقوبات جاءت لمسؤوليتها هؤلاء عن سجن
معارض روسي انتقد غزوه اوكرانيا وتمنع
العقوبات الجديده هؤلاء المسؤولين الروس
من الوصول الى حسابات بنكيه امريكيه
ومؤسسات ماليه اخرى وايضا تشمل حظرا على
التاشيرات
وصلت رئيسه البرلمان الاوروبي روبرت الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيا في زياره مفاجئه
متسولا عبرت في تغريده على تويتر عن
فرحتها بالعوده الى اوكرانيا وقالت يسرني
ان اكون مع من ضحوا بكل شيء من اجل قيمنا
وبدوره اجر وزير العدل الامريكي
زياره مفاجئه لمدينه كييف
فيف عفوا في غرب اوكرانيا
وزياده الزياره توجد جدد خلالها المسؤول
الامريكي تصميم واشنطن على محاسبه روسيا
على الجرائم التي ارتكبتها في اوكرانيا
بحسب تعبيره وقال جولاند ان وزاره العدل
الامريكيه تعمل مع نظيرتها الاوكرانيه
للتحقيق في تلك الجرائم
في الاثناء اعلن المدعي العامه الاوكراني
اندريه ان بلاده تستعد لفتح مكتب للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه واقل المدعي العامه
الاوكراني ان هذا سيسمح للمدعي العام
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بتحقيق بشكل
كامل في الجرائم الدوليه التي ارتكبت
روسيا في اوكرانيا
بينما تتركز الانظار على تطورات الوضع في
جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا خصوصا حول مدينه
باكموت تزايدت المخاوف الاوكرانيه من شن
هجوم مباغت من جهه الغرب عبر اقليم ترانس
او ترانسني
عبر او غير المعترف فيه باتجاه مدينه
اوداس
معارك ضاريه تشهدها مدينه بخموت منذ
اسابيع لم تحسن بعد لكن احتدام الوضع فيها
لم يغفي العيون موسكو يوما عن واجهه
اوكرانيا نحو البحر الاسود
اليوم تزداد مخاوف اوكرانيا من شن روسيا
هجوما مباغتا من جهه الغرب اي من اقليم
المولدوفي الذي تتمركز فيه قوات روسيه
خصوصا بعد ان اعلن مستشار الرئيس الاداره
العسكريه في اوديسا تسريع وتيره عمليات
تحصين المدينه لمنع تعرضها لهجوم حده
التوتر تصاعدت على حدود هذا الاقليم بعد
ان اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان روسيا تنشر
سفنا اضافيه بما في ذلك خمس حاملات صواريخ
وغواصتان في البحر الاسود
خطوه روسيا العسكريه بحريا ارفقتها
باتهامات لقياف بتحضيرها استفزازا عسكريا
ضد اقليم ترانسينيستريا هذه الاتهامات
كانت كفيله بتعزيز فرضيه التوجه الروسي
لاطلاق مرحله جديده من الصراع بمشاركه
الانفصاليين
الموالين لموسكو
اهميه فتح هذه الجبهه تكمن بالسعي الى
تعقيد الموقف اكثر امام كييف من خلال
توسيع رقعه المواجهات من ناحيه والعمل
بشكل مباشر على محاوله السيطره على ميناء
اوديسا في اقصى غربي البلاد من ناحيه اخرى
قالت مجله عن مسؤولين امريكيين واخرين في
النيتو قولهم ان موسكو
لبناء مصنع لطائره المسيره في روسيا وبحسب
المسؤولين الغربيين الذي نقلت عنهم فرن
بوليسي فموسكو تنوي تزويد طهران بمقاتلات
ومروحيات وانظمه دفاع جوي وقالت ان دعم
ايران لروسيا في اوكرانيا لن يقلب موازين
القوه لكنه سيرفع عدد الضحايا
افدت وكاله الانباء العراقيه بان هيئه
النزاهه اصدرت اوامر بالقبض على اربعه من
كبار المسؤولين في حكومه رئيس الوزراء
السابق مصطفى الكاظمي والحجز على اموالهم
بينما او بينهم وزير الماليه السابقه علي
علاوي قالت الوكاله ان الاوامر شملت مدير
مكتب او مدير مكتب رئيس الوزراء السابق
رائد جوحي
والسكرتيره الشخصي لرئيس مجلس الوزراء
السابق احمد نجاتي والمستشار الاعلامي
لرئيس مجلس الوزراء في الحكومه السابقه
مشرف عباس
واشارت الهيئه الى انها امرت بالقبض على
هؤلاء المسؤولين والحجز على اموالهم
المنقوله وغير المنقوله لتسهيلهم
الاستيلاء على مبالغ الامانه الضريبيه
دع المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران روبرت
مالي الى محاسبه مسؤولين عن تسمم فتيات في
مدارس ايرانيه وقال مالي على تويتر انه
يجب ان تتوقف حاله التسمم هذه ومحاسبه
الجونه مضيفا بانه لا ينبغي لاحد يمنع
فتيات ايران من مواصله التعليم الذي يعد
حقا من حقوق الانسان وضروريا لتعزيز الامن
الاقتصاديه للمراه
خطبه لابتلاع اعذار النظام الايراني
وامتصاص اخطائه تحولت لها دول الغرب فهناك
يرمي انتهاكاته بمجالاتها المتعدده ليزعم
وقوف من يصفهم بالاعداء خلف كل ما يجري في
بلاده
فصول قمع الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد ليتسرب
عبرها غاز تسبب بتسمم طالبات في المدارس
هذه ايضا تهمه الصقها بطريقه ما الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي بالغرب الذي يسعى
وفق تعبيره لاشاعه التوتر والذعر بين
الطلاب واولياء امورهم واثاره الاضطرابات
في ايران
معاناه الفتيات الايرانيات وسلبهن حق
التعليم بات موضع قلق دول غربيه عده بينها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا فهجمات السم
الخفيف فسرها السياسيون على انها استهداف
من قبل الجماعات المتشدده المعارضه لتعليم
الفتيات
يجب ان تتمكن الفتيات من الذهاب الى
المدرسه بلا خوف هذا حقهن الانساني ببساطه
يجب التحقيق بشكل كامل في كل الحالات
حالات تسمم متوسطه لمئات الفتيات اعلنت
عنها وزاره الصحه الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وبين السوق الاتهامات
والقاء اللوم وجه رئيس وزير الداخليه
والامن بمتابعه قضايا التسمم في المدارس
فيما كلف رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد باقر
قليباث اربعه لجان برلمانيه بالتحقيق
واكتشاف اسباب الحوادث وقد تم القاء القبض
على ثلاثه اشخاص اشتوها بتورطهم في القضيه
لكن الاجهزه الامنيه نفت اكتشافها لماده
سامه قد تكون السبب في تسمم الطلبه
نبقى في ايران حيث نظم محتاجون في شوارع
مدينه زهدان عاصمه بلوشستان جنوب شرق
ايران ضد نظام الملالي ورفع المحتجون
البلوش الذين خرجوا عقب صلاه الجمعه في
مظاهره رفعوا لافتات تحمل شعارات الموت
للظالم شاهم كان ام مرشدا
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
انا اوان المحاسبه
قيس سعيد يحضروا من مشاركه اجانب في
تظاهرات للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد انه انا الاوان لمحاسبه المتربصين
بالشعب بحسب وصفه سيد قال ان الاتحاد
التونسي للشغل له الحريه لتنظيم المظاهرات
لكن ليس في دعوه الاجانب للمشاركه فيها
وان ذلك امر غير مقبول مضيفا انه هناك من
يريد الافلات من المحاسبه
هناك من يريد ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
لتكن معاملاتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستانا
ذكر رئيس التونسي بمن تورط في الفساد
ومحاوله اغتيال رئيس الدوله وانه انا
الاوان لمحاسبتهم على اي شيء يحتاجون
اليوم
على
على المحاسبه
على من تورته في الفساد
هل هناك تضييق في الحريات
هل هناك دوله في العالم
تقبل
بان يعمل بعض الاطراف على اغتيال رئيس
الدوله
ولا تتم محاسبتهم بل هم تحت
حمايه الامن
وزير داخليه المكلف بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عماد الطرابلسي نف ايقاف الوزيره
طرابلسي في مطار العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
بسبب اصطحابه لمبالغ او مبلغ مالي كبير
مكتب وزير داخليه مكتب وزير داخليه حكومه
الوحده وفي تصريحات خاصه للعربيه اوضح ان
الوزيره طرابلسيه غادر باريس بعد انتهاء
زيارته للاراضي الفرنسيه التي دخلها وفقا
للاجراءات القانونيه المخوله لذلك
قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ان بلاده
حددت
214,68 مباني في مناطق الزلزال بحاجه
للهدم الفوري اثر تضررها من الزلزال ان
الاعداد النهائيه للوحدات السكنيه
والمنازل الريفيه المزمعه انشاؤها في
مناطق الزلزال ستصبح قريبا مع اوسطتضح
قريبا مع انتهاء عمليه ازاله الامطار
اعلنت زعيمه حزب الخير المعارض التركي
ميرال اكشينار عن رفض حزبها ترشيحها زعيم
المعارضه ورئيسه حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
كليتشيه القادمه
واوضحت اكشينار ان خمسه زعماء من قاده
احزاب الطاوله السداسيه قرروا ترشيح كليد
كليتش دار اوغلو رغم كل المؤشرات التي
تؤكد تقدم الرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام
اوغلو ورئيس بلديه انقره من سوريا فاج في
استطلاعات الراي مؤكده ان حزبها لن يرضخ
لضغوط الطاوله السداسيه بترشيح كليتشار
اوغلو
في المرحله الحاليه اضطر الحزب الصالح الى
الفرد واجبر على الاختيار بين الموت
والملاريا تماما كما حدث للامه التركيه
لسنوات وبالطبع لن يرضخ الحزب الصالح الى
هذا كحزب الواي اي اعربنا عن راينا في
ترشيحين اولئك الذين سمعناهم كثيرا في
الشوارع والمتاجر والساحات العامه لاكثر
من ثلاث سنوات تلك التي شهدناها في كل
مكان تقريبا اظهرتها امتنا بشده المحسوبيه
واولئك الذين رايناهم في جميع الاستطلاعات
العامه فازوا بفارق كبير على السيد
اردوغان لفتره طويله هذان الاسمان هما
عمده مدينه انقره السيد منصور يافاس وعمده
مدينه اسطنبول السيد اكرم امام اوغلو
هذا يلف الغموض وضع احزاب المعارضه بعد
تفاهم لم يدم لساعات بينها على مرشح مشترك
الامر الذي موقفها بشكل كبير في
الانتخابات
خمسه وسبعون يوما فقط تفصل الشارع التركيه
على الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه التي
ستجرى مع تاكيد اردوغان على ان الموعد لم
يتغير وسيكون بتاريخ الرابعه عشر من مايو
المقبل وفق تقرير صادر عن وكاله تمر
المعارضه التركيه بازمه خانقه بسبب الفشل
في الاتفاق على مرشح مشترك لمنافسه الرئيس
التركي الذي اتهم الاحزاب المعارضه
بالفوضى والانقسام بشان قضايا تتعلق
باداره البلاد على حسب تعبيره
ليكن هذا واضحا للجميع هذه الامه ستفعل ما
هو ضروري في الرابع عشر من مايو الشعب
التركي سيرد على هؤلاء المغرضين ولم يابه
لمن يرددون الشعارات والمقولات الفارغه
توحيد جبهه المعارضه في هذه الانتخابات
بات ضروريه لكسب المعركه السياسيه وفق
مراقبين وفشلوا الحكومه التعاطي مع عمليات
الانقاذ والاغاثه سيشكل ورقه رابحه
بالنسبه لها حيث ان قاده الطاوله السداسيه
للمعارضه التركيه تقول انها ستعلن خلال
ايام مرشحها المشتركه لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ووسطت تكهنات المتداوله اكد زعيم
الحزب الصالح القومي التركيه المعارض ان
الحزب لن يستسلم لمحاولات محاصرته حيث طرح
ترشيح رئيس بلديه انقره من سوريا واش
ورئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوبلو لخوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن الاحزاب الخمسه
الاخرى لم تقبل بذلك وقامت بترشيح كمالك
الاجدار اوغلو لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تضارب التصريحات طرح سيناريوهات المتعدده
ابرزها خروج المعارضه باكثر من مرشح بهدف
ارباك ساحه المؤيدين للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وسط تحليلات تشير الى ارت فاع
حدود المعارضه في تحقيق فوز على اردوغان
بعد كارثه الزلزال من جهه او تصويت اقل من
نصف ناخبين لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه ما
سيسمح للرئيس التركي بالتغلب في صناديق
الاقتراع
اعلنت الحكومه السويسريه تخفيف العقوبات
المفروضه على سوريا منذ عام 2011 من اجل
تسيل عمل المنظمات الانسانيه التي تقدم
المساعده لمنكوبي زلزال وجاء في بيان
الحكومه السويسريه ان هذه الخطوات تهدف
الى تسهيل اقامه علاقات تجاريه ضروريه
لعمل المنظمات الانسانيه في سوريا
قتلت اثنان من قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في
شمال محافظه الرقه قصف المدفعيه التركيه
على المنطقه وفقا لوكاله انباء الفرات
الجيش التركي استخدم المدافع الثقيله
وقذائف الهاون انطلاقا من مناطق سيطره
فصائل المعارضه ملحقه الضرر بعدد من
المنازل دون معلومات عن الاصابات بين
المدنيين
اعلنت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه عن
تنفيذها مع شركاء اخرين
عمليه ضد عناصر تنظيم داعش في العراق
وسوريا الشهر الماضي اوضحت القياده ان هذه
العمليات اسفلت عن مقتل 22 عنصرا من
التنظيم واعتقالي 25 اخرين
التمويل الملك كان اهم الركائز التي اعتمد
عليها تنظيم داعش للبقاء لجا الى السيطره
على المناطق النفطيه واقام شبكه اموال
سريه وحينما انهار واصبح افراده في
المخيمات وداخل السجون لجا الى طريقه اخرى
للوصول الى اول الخيط توجهنا الى المخيمات
التي تحتجز فيها عائلات تنظيم شمال شرق
سوريا داخل مخيم الروج ومكتب مكتب للصرافه
وتحويل الاموال للداعشيات اعلنا
نخضع او على بالفعل يخضع لرقابه قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وفي الباطن تخطيط يجري
داخل الخيام الداعشيات حملات لجمع
التبرعات وعمليات ابتزاز وتهريب تشرف
عليها خلايا التنظيم
امام نافذه مكتب الصرافه ينتظرنا بترقب
وصول حوالات ماليه مشهد سيبدو مالوفا لو
كان خارج اسوار هذا المكان لكن هن زوجات
مقاتل داعش وهذا مكتب الصرافه داخل مخيم
روج الذي ياوي عائله التنظيم وجله من
الاجانب
تسمح قوى الامن في المخيم التابعه لاداره
الذاتيه شمال سوريا لمكاتب الصرافه بالعمل
داخل مخيمات الدواعش تحت رقبتها ايصال
مبالغ ماليه المقيمين هنا والذين يقولون
انها من اقاربهم
لمساعدتهم على تكاليف الحياه
كم عاده ترسل لك
50 دولار نعم شهريا
[موسيقى]
يمكن لي كل عائله داخل المخيم تسلم ما بين
شهريا رسميا يقول القائمون على المخيمات
ان الاموال ترسل من ادلب التي تسيطر عليها
فصائل مواليه لتركيا او من داخل تركيا
نفسها
المصادر الاموال كلياتهم من اهاليون على
اليوتيوب اهاليون موجودين بادلب اغلبيتهم
كلياتهم
ومن تركيا ويلي خارج
نطاق دوله تركيا او من اتلف كمان بعض
الاهالي منهم بيبعتوا على تركيا من تركيا
بيبعتوهم عنا او من تركيا على ادلب ومن
ادلب كمان بيجولا لماذا ترك ذلك
تركيا كلياتهم هلا ما بعرف يعني هي اساس
المقر هي
السماح بوصول الاموال لعائله التنظيم
يبرره المسؤولون هنا باسباب انسانيه
فمساعده المنظمات الاغاثيه غير كافيه للسد
احتياجات العائلات اليوميه لكن الخطير عدم
قدره احد على تحديد او تتبع مصادر التمويل
تضمن
هلا اضمن النمو من داعش مثلا في 100 طريقه
داعش تقدر تحوليها بالاث اذا عم يجي من
مناطق
نصر داعش وهيكل وجميله واحده يعني ما يعني
ما في كبسه
نجحت نساء التنظيف في مخيمات شمال سوريا
مره كثيره على مدار السنوات الماضيه في
جمع الاموال عبر حملات تبرعات باسماء
مشفره في منصات ماليه كما يحصلن على
مساعدات ماليه من متعاطفين مع داعش
والغطاء الابرز عائلتهن
بعض التحقيق والدراسه عن هالوضع
الاغلبيه لانه في بعض التواصلات عن طريق
الهواتف
وبشكل علني انه نبعث هالمصاري للاخوات
الموجودين اللي يقاومون ضمن المخيم حتى
يقوم بتربيه اولادهم بشكل افضل
وعن طريق الهواتف بيجون توجيهات يعني هل
اموال كيف يتصرفوا فيها
اما الغايه فتمويل محاولات هروبهن او شراء
اسلحه او حتى شراء ولاءات النازحين
واللاجئين داخل المخيمات معلومات اوصلت
الاداره الذاتيه للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش
ودول غربيه تم اتخاذ بعض التدابير بالفتره
الماضيه فقط يتطلب عمل مستمر لانه يعني
بلكي بعض البنوك تم كشف عنهم بيحاولون
يغيرون
بنوك اخرى او لمصادر اخرى
مصادر مداخل مخيم الهول رفضت الافصاح عن
هويتها كشفت ان خلايا داعش هددت عمال
اغاثه محليين يعملون مع منظمات دوليه اما
للحصول على اموال منهم او لاجبارهم على
مساعدتهم في تهريب اشخاص من داخل المخيم
فالتمويل والترهيب وفكر التنظيم المتشدد
ادوات يحافظ عليها استمرار بقائه وان كان
ذلك في المخيمات او السجون صار بن عيشوبه
العربيه من شمال شرق سوريا
اشتبكت شرطه مكافحه الشغب مع مجموعه صغيره
من المتظاهرين في وسط العاصمه اليونانيه
اثناء على اهم شيء تجمع الليلي في ساحه
تكريما لسبعه وخمسين شخصا قتلوا في اسواق
كارثه قطار في اليونان وقد اطلقت شرطه
مكافحه الشغب الغاز المسيل للدموع على عدد
من المتظاهرين الذين رشقوا الشرطه
بالحجاره
ختاموا هذه النشره الى العناوين
الرئيس الامريكي والمستشار الالماني
يتعهدان بمعاقبه روسيا بسبب حربها في
اوكرانيا
هيئه النزاع النزاهه العراقيه تامر بالقبض
على اربعه مسؤولين سابقين بينهم وزير
الماليه علي علاوي
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران يدعو الى
محاسبه المسؤولين عن تسمم فتيات بمدارس
ايرانيه
ودائما مشاهدينا العربيه ضغط مزيدا من
المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق معدودات في
نشره اخرى الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]